welcome back to CBS this morning we're
going to begin with this Mike Bloomberg
one of the world's richest people is
pushing back against claims that he
wants to buy the Democratic presidential
nomination we spoke to him about that it
was his first TV interview since he
joined the 20/20 race last month in our
exclusive conversation the former New
York City Mayor also discussed his plan
to fight gun violence we met him in
Aurora Colorado yesterday afternoon
where he addressed that issue with the
community that has lost 12 people in a
shooting rampage back in 2012 we're in
Colorado Mayor because you chose this
place to launch your big gun initiative
and I'm wondering as I sat there looking
at the families hearing the families
because they have heard this before
we're gonna do it we're gonna get it
done there will be some changes why do
you think you're different this time I
understand the problem you have to go
and look at the victims before you can
really understand what they're going
through the emotional problems they have
the financial problems somebody in your
family gets killed how do you take care
of everybody who's going to take care of
the kids who pays for the funeral part
of the answer is you got to go out and
look at the problem rather than just
talk about it in an academic sense
you've got to be able to go to the
legislature and convince them at least
argue with them at least ask ask them to
participate and say look here's why you
should do it
it's leadership and we don't seem to
have that when it comes to guns
you had the NRA which was the leader the
NRA has basically been beaten we've gone
and they've lost most of their funding
sources their top management is in chaos
you think you can work with the NRA no
but I don't think I think you can't
avoid the NRA you core you can beat them
so you intend to work around the NRA
because what you're saying well I think
you just don't paint and you just don't
make much of the NRA you don't have to
go talk to them at all well it would be
no surprise to you that your fellow
candidates are not so glad to see you
get in Elizabeth Warren suggested you're
trying to buy the election Bernie
Sanders says as a billionaire you can
run even the dumbest person on the earth
and pay for it you see what they're all
getting here they're all making yeah the
point they're making is
if that know what the point they're
making is it's okay if they ask other
people for all their money and it will
help their careers whereas if somebody
goes out and makes the money themselves
and gives it away I give an enormous
richly all my income goes to public
health issues in education and the arts
and the environment things that I care
about and I think I could do a lot of
good for the country if I could become
president and so using some of those
monies to fund the campaign is fine what
is true is a second time my father made
six thousand dollars the best year of
his life I don't come from money nobody
gave me if headstart
I had my parents gave me that an
education and public school system and
in in Medford Massachusetts and they
taught me ethics and they taught me hard
work I worked my way through college and
then I worked for fifteen years I got
fired I started a company the company
turned out to be phenomenally successful
you've been very successful money away
what's wrong with all of that and then I
turned and they're criticizing me for it
I don't know ask them what they're doing
why didn't they do that they had a
chance to go out and make a lot of money
and and how much of their own money do
they put into their campaigns but I
think the point that they're making a
lot of people are making is you're a
billionaire who was buying this election
what is your response to this I'm not
buying anymore I'm doing exactly the
same thing they're doing except that I
am using my own money they're using
somebody else's money and those other
people expect something from them nobody
gives you money if they don't expect
something and I don't want to be bought
I want to get to a couple of personal
issues because you would be the first
modern-day single president but we all
know in New York you are not an eligible
bachelor your significant other Diana
Taylor is a very accomplished highly
respected high admired woman would she
be our de facto first lady is she
playing a role in your campaign she's
playing a role
hey number one number two we've only
been living together for 19 years and I
think it's fair if I can speak for her
as well neither of us have any plans to
change living together we would do you
all think about getting married not a
subject I'm going to discuss with you
dear well I am curious I didn't know
what had been that long okay you didn't
answer what it only seems like half that
way but you didn't answer the question
would she be our de facto first lady yes
yes who is a real Mike Bloomberg I was
thinking you were a Democrat then you
were a Republican then you were an
independent and now you're a Democrat
who are you I am a social liberal fiscal
moderate who is basically nonpartisan I
grew up as a Democrat in Massachusetts
there are no Republicans I moved to New
York where I was a Democrat there are no
Republicans I couldn't become mayor on
the Democratic line the Republicans said
well you can run as a Republican in New
York City the mayor's job is not a
partisan job so I did but you could have
voted me on a different line we have a
complicated most of America is in the
middle that most people are science do
believe that most of them of the public
is in the middle but I think it is most
people would say whether they like my
views or not they would say he's at
least honest and genuine probably say
smart but not everybody would agree with
that but I think they'd all say
hard-working and honest hard-working and
honest everybody that knows him
definitely says that in the words of
that great philosopher Tiffany Haddish
he ready he ready I mean he's ready for
the fight he's up for it he says he's a
people person I said I never thought of
you really as a people person he goes
yeah I'm very much a people person he
likes being out there on the campaign
trail he knows there was issues that are
gonna come up we talked to him for over
40 minutes and those were big chunks
that you saw this morning but there's so
much more than the conversation it's
gonna be it's gonna add a lot to the
races be interesting to see it's not
gonna shake controls are very tough
issue it's a nose it's not easy but you
know what he said Tony he said
even if I don't win this nomination this
is something that I'm going to focus on
that I'm going to work on and I'm going
to make a change he feels that strongly
in that partially well we've took this
about this before but Mike Bloomberg
doesn't enter a race if he think he
doesn't think there's a path to win it
so he's obviously seen numbers that
makes him believe exactly he could win
he's obviously heard about support that
he can receive from people that haven't
said who that is both Democrats and
Republicans so it's it adds an
interesting dynamic to this campaign you
can hear more of our conversation with
Mike Bloomberg as I mentioned we talk
for over 40 minutes so there is a lot
there there on today CBS this morning
podcast the candidate discusses the
Democratic debates what he would look
for in a vice presidential candidate
he's got some ideas about that his
health he says he's feeling good listen
wherever you get your podcasts